imaginaire aux victimes soviétiques
morts durant la seconde guerre mondiale
et représentants de cinq ambassades
russie biélorussie tadjikistan arménie
azerbaïdjan se sont réunis pour une
cérémonie de dépôt de gerbe au pied du
monument fleurs de russie soldat
prisonnier de guerre ou encore civils
près de 4500 personnes
on repose dans ce cimetière français et
commémoration à laquelle a participé
l'ambassadeur de russie en france
aleksei guskov qui a tenu à saluer la
mémoire de ces soviétique reposant sur
le sol français donnent à cette
cérémonie traditionnelle est très
importante pour nous je elle existe
depuis déjà 40 ans ce monument a été
inauguré en 1981 politique et puis si tu
plus de 5000 militaires prisonniers de
guerre soldats et partisans sont
enterrés ici pour nous il s'agit de
l'une des cérémonies les plus
importantes en france
une cérémonie à la mémoire de nos pères
grand-père et arrière-grand-père qui
sont morts pendant la guerre